The most important issue facing the British
electorate is their own self-government.
Under the European Union, more and more power
has flowed to Brussels.
The British Parliament is less and less important
in setting British domestic policy.
Parliament can’t reverse decisions that
are made in Brussels by bureaucrats and diplomats,
and people all over the European Union have
given this issue the name “democratic deficit.”
I’ve always thought that the economic issues
were secondary for the British, indeed, for
everybody in the Europe.
Nobody is going to argue with a continent-wide
free trade zone, but honestly, the founders
of the European Union had something very different
in mind.
It’s fundamental to the European Union itself
that the people shouldn’t be allowed to
have too much say over these decisions.
So I would say to the Brits: Get out now because
this may be your only chance.
If you don’t take it, you’re going to
become a county in a larger Europe.